as you don't know
don't to avoid
this
sleep it sounds like such a nice spell
doesn't it it's like something the first
level Mary Poppins would cast in the
Julie Andrews role-playing game a wizard
waves his hand and goblins stretch and
yawn but down their swords fluff up
their shields take a little nap and you
know what we do with napping goblins
don't you we slits their warty throats
so really the spell should be called
create slaughterhouse a tensors floating
discs now this is a really neat idea for
a spell it creates a magical platform
that a wizard can use to carry his stuff
kind of like the equivalent of those
wheelie carts that old ladies have the
problem is that this is a spell that
you'll never ever memorized if you want
to live in D&D Wizards only get a
certain number of spells per day and if
you're facing down an umber Hulk or an
ogre jelly or an Oprah Winfrey and the
only spell you have left is the I was
too cheap to hire a henchman spell while
you're going to be getting out a new
character sheet and on that character
sheet under spells memorize the first
thing you should ride is not tensors
floating discs d+ magic missile now
missile is actually a really old word
that originally had nothing to do with
laser guiding or fallout shelters but at
the same time I don't think there's a
single DNT player who upon hearing the
name of the spell for the first time
didn't think of Merlin pulling an ICBM
out of his hat presumably an ICBM with
stars and crescent moons on it but no a
magic missile is just a magical arrow a
magical arrow that does about the same
amount of damage is a regular arrow
except with regular arrows you get more
than one a day so I think the magical
incantation for the spell is I should
have rolled up a ranger b-
charmed person it's good that charm
person is a first level spell because it
introduces the new player to a very
important part of the dnd experience
heated arguments over the rules for
instance one version of the charm person
rules reads the victim will believe that
the magic user is its best friend and
will try to defend the magic user
against any threat so many things to
argue about exactly how do orcs treat
their best friends what does it mean to
try to defend the magic user does
throwing a rock and running away count
and how come every time we're collecting
money for pizza you're in the bathroom
B+ ventriloquism now this Bell gets
memorized exactly twice the first time
the DM is nice and lets you use it to
trick the ogre into walking off the
cliff looking for the ice cream man the
second time he decides that he's tired
to be using things like creativity and
initiative instead the darn rules that
he paid thirty dollars for and he
doesn't let it work in the ogre kicks
your butt which you know is just as well
because arcane master of the mystic arts
and guy who does old vaudeville routine
should not be synonymous d
you